now we're going to get dark and that's
why i was like let's let's go slow a
little bit with this one because
when i saw this op-ed this is from march
15th star tribune
near george floyd square revolution by
day the evolution by night
i saw this and i'm like oh this will be
interesting you know they're going to
talk about you know antifa
i actually assumed they were going to be
i thought it was going to be positive
i thought they were going to be like
these activists have come and they've
helped us and
they've brought all this goodness and
and organization
and then i just got a couple paragraphs
in and it just got so
incredibly dark i'm scared for these
people man i'm scared for what's going
on
and it's it's horrifying to me that you
know they they have the like barricade
saying
no way no no as in like mentally no
justice and i'm willing to bet there are
a lot of
well-to-do liberal types they hear about
this stuff these autonomous zones and
they're like good for the activists
they don't care about the locals they
don't care about what they're saying and
they will do nothing to help these
people
this story i'm not going to read through
every little bit of it but
i'll read a little bit right now to give
an introduction to what's going on they
say
as neighbors of 38th street and chicago
avenue also known as george floyd square
or the autonomous zone
we are witnessing a revolution by day
and a de-evolution by night
prayer gatherings cancelled rallies
cancelled visitors arriving with flowers
in hand only to retreat to their cars
when greeted by the sound of gunshots
neighbors ducking for cover behind our
houses children in tow
the spiritual health of our community
the feeling of being connected to
something larger than ourselves is
collapsing
here's an account of some of the events
of the past 10 days on
one block adjacent to george floyd
square
where police are met by hostile groups
when responding to our repeated 9-1-1
calls
march 6 5 45 pm a 30-year-old volunteer
is killed in the zone by gunshot
people in the zone are seen picking up
shell casings and throwing them into
city garbage
loading the gunshot victim into a car to
drive him to the hospital
8 20 pm neighbors call 9-1-1 again
as multiple shots ring out children
listen march 7th
six garages along our alley are hit by
gunfire
one with its owner inside a car crashes
through a fence into a family's backyard
an 18 month old had been playing by the
fence minutes earlier
5 pm 30 shots hit cars and windows
and siding of at least one house
narrowly missing residents watching tv
parents and children out biking and
walking on a sunny day duck behind
houses
children watch bullets kicking up dust
in the street
a zone leader visits a bullet-riddled
house to comfort the family
while others from the zone are observed
picking up shell casings behind her
march 8 2 30 pm multiple shots fired
a man is photographed perched atop cut
foods with an assault rifle on a tripod
children cry zone medics are offered to
visit
neighbors and provide mental health
support to those being traumatized
9 50 pm 30 shots ring out a person
complains to a neighbor that the
neighbor is parked too close to the
person's car
a zone occupant with no connection to
the other parties
fires multiple shots into the neighbor's
car and house
the neighbor a military veteran is in
the driver's seat and
recognizes an assault rifle with a 30
round clip
the shooter walks back into the zone
four police squad
squads caravan through and meet the
neighbor nearby 10 16 pm
a second 911 call provides a description
of the shooter who remains in the area
appearing to wait for some target
police have just received a call about a
teen and adult shot two miles away
resources exhausted the police do not
respond to our call
the shooter in the zone walks away 10 45
pm third 9-1-1 call of the night
as some neighbors are picking up shell
casings people near the first statue in
the zone repeatedly yell
get the f out of here then a gun is
fired from near the first statue
four men come out of the zone to tell
neighbors they weren't shooting at you
the neighbors asked if they are zone
security and are told no but one man
reports he has his gun
neighbors ask how to protect themselves
and are told the best thing to do
is fill the street corners with garbage
containers to block off our streets
there's more there's more i'm not going
to read through literally everything
they just talk about 9 15 p.m march 12th
30 shots from inside the zone
i'll point out a few things i think need
to be corrected i do not believe
this they mention a person you know
witness recognizes a
a third an assault rifle with a 30 round
clip i do not believe
there was someone there with like a clip
fed m1 garand that was
modified for full auto or something like
that i think star tribune
the people who live in this neighborhood
don't know much about guns
and what they're actually saying is that
someone had a rifle of some sort with a
30 round magazine
i if it is true however that they do
understand the context of assault rifle
meaning select fire rifle
what they're telling us is that somebody
was perched atop a building in this area
with a fully automatic rifle
on a tripod now i really doubt it was
full auto this person probably was just
thinking they were going to protect the
neighborhood
and they mounted a ar-15 of some sort
rifle
semi-automatic on a tripod with a 30
round magazine
i don't know why they would need to do
that unless the police have been
defunded
extremists have taken over the area and
residents are now cowering in fear
and you know what's interesting they say
medics are being provided for those who
are being traumatized
you know typically when we hear about
these antifa zones and trauma
we usually fan it off like a bunch of
weak pathetic college kids who think
hearing a fart is going to make you
is going to traumatize you or that
journalist who fired an ar-15
probably a 556 and then got ptsd from
doing it
no i think these families are absolutely
going to be suffering ptsd because it
sounds like they're in a war zone
cars crashing through a fence 30 rounds
ringing out
at some point a 30 year old being shot
and killed we heard about that story
when it happened
the police tried to come and render aid
they were barred and then what happens
in these autonomous zones
the extremists pick up the evidence the
shell casings and they destroy all the
evidence
when when the security in the i believe
was the chas
executed those kids for 10 minutes were
just unloading round after round
hundreds of rounds they reported
what did they do afterwards well the
police couldn't get in so they stripped
the vehicle of evidence so that nobody
would
know who did it and what they did now
it's been happening in minneapolis
all while we have this trial going on i
don't know how
you have a i can't believe they're
having this trial for chauvin
in minneapolis right now they need to
move him to bumpkinville somewhere
far away from all of this stuff all of
the press all of the gunshots all of the
settlement
and then just let people in different
community hear this because there's no
way this guy's getting a fair trial
this is this is where we're at man i
think that's the point right like
why did they overcharge them in the
first place why did they why was the
settlement number
public aren't settlements usually
private isn't that the whole point a lot
of times
is we're gonna settle this and not talk
about the terms i guess it's the city so
maybe they have to reveal it
but it seems to me if you're going to
settle and put that statement that
number out there
what you're basically saying is we think
we're guilty and you know why settle it
now
why did they settle now it was
sabotaging the trial
yes absolutely yes uh they sabotage
everything is about sabotaging this it
seems to me that they're setting us up
for
a tinderbox it is a tinderbox it is
being stuffed filled with kindling
they are just waiting for the spark i
don't get how people are calling 9-1-1
from inside the zone to the police
outside the zone and
it's not being treated as like a hostage
situation it's it that's what it sounds
like it's like a federal hostage
situation and the city is not willing to
well biden's not gonna do anything well
the city itself they're the one
these are the people that actually
defunded the police after all the riots
right these are one of the jurisdictions
that actually did
they did so the elected officials
believed that the people that elected
them put them into power to make
decisions like this to defund the police
man could you imagine living like that i
look man i i
i everybody knows i grew up on the south
side of chicago i remember i'd be you
know sleeping and you hear
pow pow pow in the middle of the night
and you just
you just you still you're laying down so
what can you do you know go to the floor
if
you hear it closely but usually it's far
away i remember hearing from a friend of
mine i was talking to him on the phone
late at night because we were like going
to go skate or something
and then he's like oh dude hold on a
second i s
yeah there's a couple people dragging
dude they're dragging a body
he basically said what he told me was
that he saw two people going through an
alley carrying a rolled up carpet with
feet sticking out the back of it
even even grunk in a place like this i
could not imagine
30 rats 30 shots ringing out
cars crashing through fences dude
they're shooting into cars with people
in them they're shooting into people's
garages like through the garage
now if you read the police bought or
from washington dc from any given day
you're going to have
all of those things on there yeah but
that's what i'm saying
plus 10 extra murders plus all kinds of
over like
it's insane and if you read the police
waters from my neighborhood even where
there's like a million dollar houses it
terrifying but this is all within
basically what like 50 yards of the same
intersection they said
in this op-ed this is one block that's
insane one block so
it's it's they call it 30th they're
saying 38 38th in chicago is the george
floyd square
so there's probably four adjacent blocks
you know going to one going you know
east west north and south or whatever
the directions they have built
maybe it's mates north by northwest or
something and uh
this is one of those blocks adjacent to
the memorial
we we we write about that story man
where the 30 year old volunteer was shot
and killed but this is just so much like
what happened in seattle
you'd think the first time this happened
then
police would take it seriously but but i
want to add to this
when will there ever be a federal
response to what's going on with these
extremists because i i'm willing to bet
you know they mentioned that one of
these guys who was shooting at nothing
to do with the neighbors who are arguing
i'm willing to bet we call them the
tourists
right so you know since occupy me and
several of uh many journalists friends
of mine we would notice there were
always these similar people we would see
at the same events we knew their names
we called them tourists because they
would even fly to china
a couple of them flew to turkey to
engage in protests
for what reason are you in china
protesting okay there's a lot of things
protests in china for sure
but they were protesting mainland china
for like very specific chinese domestic
policy
and i'm like what is this who are these
people why are they doing this i bring
this up not to say that
i don't know what that is they're doing
how many of these people in the
autonomous zone are not from minnesota
how many of them crossed state lines
potentially armed
and and are committing these crimes
burning man was canceled this year
so look if you look at the murder
numbers this is happening all over the
country
murder numbers are back up to their
1990s levels
wow 1990s which is coming out of like
when dc was called the most you know the
murder capital of the world
dc was dc dc was the murder capital of
the world
wow in the late 80s and that's when i
first moved to dc and that's when i got
my first choice
as well thanks dad that's when i got my
first taste here
so um you know on one hand this really
makes me feel
sympathy for people that do live with
this kind of violence
and it's not maybe as extreme but they
do live with it i mean we're talking
hundreds and hundreds of murders in dc
with a population of 500
000 yeah that's a lot okay per capita
and it was so bad that after the 1968
riots the city gets burned out
crack cocaine crime everybody
everybody left the city anybody that
could lead the city left the city
and anybody that could leave the city
and that's it anybody that has this
the could is the key there yeah people
who are impoverished
get trapped in these places and it
creates a cycle of poverty crime and
violence
totally and when i was doing real estate
development in the 90s we would go
around rehabbing houses and i remember
specifically there were always
the houses always had bars on the
windows some of the houses had bars on
the doors and the windows
some of them had bars on the windows on
the second floor
okay but the cake wow the cake is when i
figured out
when i had did a house that had bars on
the roof hatch
on the inside on the second floor of
their townhouse there's a roof hatch to
go up into the attic and up into the
roof
they had bars inside their house on the
second floor
roof hatch because they were they had to
pay somebody to come in there and weld
it and it's
because someone broke into their because
people had been breaking into homes
through the attics and invading people's
houses
so that's like a level of violence that
people were accustomed to in the 80s and
in the early 90s in dc this sounds
familiar on the heels of what riots
breakdown of order people moving out the
police stepping back
and just allowing this crime to take
over by design in this case
this is this is a war zone what they're
describing yeah
i've been i've been in civil conflict
i've not been in full-scale war
i have not reported from places where
you've got you know
active you know belligerent militaristic
national whatever
but i have been in countries i was in
egypt during the revolution i was in
ukraine during
you know a lot of that conflict molotovs
were being thrown
people were getting shot venezuela i'll
tell you this based on what they're
reporting
i felt safe like reading this and i'll
preface this with i
i don't know what it's actually like to
be there on the ground but when i was in
venezuela
nowhere near as scary if if what they're
going through right now with an
autonomous zone
sounds more deadly than caracas which is
the murder capital of the world now
i can only imagine i mean something's
got to be done about it
this is this is i mean look there's
photos i guess there's a photo of a
giant
black lives matter communist fist right
in the middle
is this what what people can expect when
this this ideological faction continues
to gain power and expand
all right here's two things that are
really important one black lives matter
and antifa should be acting as
decentralized cells not trying to hold
a territory like this and using politics
and other punctuated moments to get
their agenda across
holding territory for them seems like a
strategic failure
right because they're just setting up
this environment which they can be
blamed for virtually
everything right but at the same time it
strikes me as being so
bad for them such a
polit a propaganda failure right
that it seemed if i were designing a
circumstance to make black lives matter
and antifa look bad
i would encourage people to go to this
autonomous zone and start shooting
things up and start blowing things up
or you would encourage them to create
the autonomous zone because you know
what what invariably leads to when cops
don't come anymore it seems like such a
bad idea
and maybe they're this just this stupid
but it seems like such a bad idea that
it feels like it's somebody else doing
it it's like an info
i mean look they the the fist symbol
they use is literally the communist
fist symbol you know so i'm not going to
pretend that a lot of these people
realize
what it is like they don't they don't
know the core ideology behind a lot of
what they're doing
there are a lot of people who and this
is to be fair and be
respectful support black lives matter
because they genuinely believe police go
around
hunting down black people thousands in a
year right and it's not true
it is the big lie pushed by the media
over and over again
and the algorithms of big tech to
convince people basically the apocalypse
is happening
and it's just not true are there
problems yes should cops bail
accountable when they break the law
absolutely
should we should we get an inquiry and
investigation whenever someone dies then
the police officer you bet
whenever someone dies we should figure
out what happened but these people
have adopted a fringe violent extremist
ideology
and right now you know what they're
saying these articles come out and
they're like racist extremists are the
biggest threat
white supremacists are the biggest
threat okay okay sure fine
i don't care if you want to say that the
biggest threat by all means law
enforcement do your job
target the biggest threat but can we
have a real conversation about how
serious
this threat is as well so i'll say it's
not the biggest threat but it's
certainly a big threat
to whom threat to whom civilians
well who who are white supremacists the
biggest threat to
oh minorities but we know that that's
not actually the one
supremacist what do you mean well the
number of murders
of black people committed by other black
people far exceed any white supremacy
murder
can we get a fact check on that i'm
pretty darn sure about that
it far exceeds going so uh white people
more are more likely to kill white
people black people are more
black people are more likely to kill
black people yeah so you know in these
areas it's particularly interesting when
you have
white progressive antifa types going
into minority areas and burning down
black businesses and contributing to
that that castness conflict but but i
think they're specifically talking about
terror and political
not not like random street violence and
muggings
right so here's the irony of that it's
written by the
the white dominant i'm using their words
white dominant supremacy culture
the white oppressive structures the
government is saying
that the biggest threat is white
supremacists to whom
well to the government they're not
actually right they're saying terrorism
right but they're not actually talking
about who the threat to to minority
people
they're very specifically coming at it
from a white power structure perspective
saying i see white supremacists are the
biggest problem so
ironically if minorities are picking up
that as
as as a position i don't think that's
actually what they're saying
i i see what you're saying they
definitely fear the threat from
the queue people and you know far-right
groups storming the capital and stuff
but we just had that that attra that
atrocity happened with that
in-cell guy who went to the asian
massage parlor so
this is what i'm saying i'm not here to
argue they're wrong
by all means if the experts come out and
say
racist extremists and white supremacists
are the biggest threat we face i say
well then thank god you guys are on top
of this one no joke
if you guys are actually tracking down
the extremists they're going to stop the
violent criminals from getting
committing atrocities
then i'm glad you're there because we
don't want that to happen okay great
now do you have any extra police or
federal agents that can stop
the autonomous zone extremism that's
putting people under occupation and
making them live in fear
and under violence into the boot of
these extremists because i don't
understand why they can't do that i
don't understand why they can send out a
dozen agents for
for a garage pole rope for that nascar
driver because they thought it was
racist
but they can't do anything to stop this
because the government doesn't want it
in minneapolis in minnesota the people
don't want it
the elected officials don't want it the
city councils are the ones that move to
defund the police
that entire community is affecting sorry
infected top to bottom apparently with
this mind disease
right and the part that you pointed well
not at the bottom these are the ones who
are in the op-ed saying
people are fleeing and we refuse sure we
want our city back sure
so they're coming into close contact
with reality
now what all this all these people who
are like oh yeah black lives matter to
fund the police i for i'm all for that
who could be against black lives matter
well this is what happens when you've
been taken as a
unwitting foot soldier in a war where
you don't know what the end goal really
is
or any of the ideology behind what
you're doing what you're saying
and you just become a pawn and now these
people are figuring out that they're
pawns
but there's no one in that political
apparatus that wants federal agents to
come in there and fix this
or state troopers to come in there and
fix this and they've already told their
local police not to fix it this is what
they wanted
that's true so i i feel bad for these
individuals who are there
yes now now coming face to face with
these policies
and you know what i'll add on top of
this first and foremost anybody who's
facing a distressing
war-torn chaotic moment like this you
got my sympathy
and i want you to get the right if you
come to me and you're like hey man i was
wrong defunding the police was a big
mistake please can you help us i will
say yes
yes so if they're coming out and they're
saying that now i will also say to all
the people who voted for it and still
sit back and say it's a good thing well
then you get what you deserve
yeah you vote for it you want it don't
don't i'm not going to interfere i've
been thinking about this for that
democracy 15 minutes
during war world war ii i think 20
million
soldier deaths 50 million civilian
deaths or something like that the number
was like two to one
in war and that's in like an organized
soldier on soldier conflict when you see
this
city violence it's the civilian death
and destruction that is just goes
under the radar but you know what you
know what i gotta say it
if you don't pay attention to the news
if you do
nothing evil triumphs but the problem
that yeah i agree with you 100
you gotta dig the problem that we have
today is the world has become too
complex and it's impossible for an
individual to make sense of the world
determine right and wrong
up from down it is impossible to do that
today
right because we live in a purposefully
polluted information space
it's impossible for anybody working yes
outside of that space
you know so you you expect the
journalist to distill this information
and give you an accurate world view so
you can make better
better choices instead what you get now
is rage bait garbage
ridiculous stories drama con you know
articles
so-and-so's fighting with so and so or
whatever that's what you get
here's the latest bigot tucker carlson
is now donald trump saith brian stelter
oh we know why he did that because cnn's
ratings dropped by
something like 50 some odd percent and
then another like 47 in the key demo
so they they're they're they're they're
on dire straits they're the only white
devil
they need a new villain to to report on
to keep everyone all going crazy it's
not going to work no one cares about
tucker carlson brian
no they tried doing marjorie taylor
green but nobody cares about a freshman
congresswoman
okay well how about tucker he's got the
biggest show on fox news sorry bro
people are hitting me up a lot of people
hit me up and they're like tim
youtube is suppressing my channel right
now what's happening as soon as the
election was over they started hitting
my channel like no no
no no one's suppressing your channel
nobody cares okay
during i mean look we did we were on the
show on january 6th
we had like you know 80 000 people
watching 100 000 a million views in the
first night
live viewership and then like 800 or 900
000 you know video on demand views
and now viewership goes way down because
we're coming off of that political
season
fortunately for us we're a small podcast
with you know small business
things are going well but for cnn oh no
they're
they're they're getting crushed and it's
getting it's getting brutal to finish
that last point though on this
complexity of the world
it was once upon a time i believe
rational to be ignorant
of politics you're not going to be able
to deduce everything you're not going to
be able to figure it all out and make a
vote that's going to count
right because it's never just but side
by one vote so there was a little
rationality to being
ignorant but today it is irrational to
be ignorant if you are ignorant and you
just accept what's given to you over
the mainstream media and through the
legacy and through our institutions
you will end up fat sick chained to a
desk
in debt working for a corporation
wearing a mask staying at home
putting your kid in quarantine next to
you listening to him cry
out for you and you'll think that we
live in a world where white supremacy is
the biggest problem
and that black lives matter just means
we want black people to have a good life
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you